in tonight's view on The View here's Joy
Behar calling young Republicans dumb
this business about the Aging that keeps
coming up
talking about the Young Generation The
Young the generation of Republicans are
dumbest mommy you've got Marjorie Taylor
green you've got oh wait a second Lauren
Bubblehead Matt Gates you have all these
people who went along with the
Insurrection who believe that Trump won
oh marjories out there oh Trump won by a
landslide they're Liars there and they
are the new generation of the Republican
Party Joy sure loves running her mouth
she should but she should it's the only
running she does Emily
so what did you make of this feedback V
back vbac is what you called him I don't
care if you disagree or agree with him
that dude is not dumb
no and that's that is what was so
ridiculous everything that comes out of
her mouth is ridiculous but for her to
make that kind of point about someone
that we all know that that regardless
how you feel about his politics or him
running that he is undeniably brilliant
is so ridiculous and for her to lump him
in with her whole point which made no
sense he has a degree in biology from
Harvard he went to Yale law school he
sold his business for 150 million I
think something insane like that she
went to Stony but like it's like save it
Joy she's on The View save it dude she's
on The View together they can't get 10
brain cells together
thank you God she's an idiot clown and a
fright wig I think you know Rob
yes yes
um I this is I mean I look I don't have
a problem with anybody calling anybody
dumb really no oh okay by the way I say
worse things
uh about the view that's right yes
there's no question in there there's no
question I'm just staring at oh you're
staring at me okay
um I what I uh I really think the issue
here is is the young part that's what
bugs are right that they're young people
yeah and like there is this I mean I
know we having sort of cultural War
political world all that stuff but we're
really going to have a generational
world when Ancient Ancient gargoyles on
TV and in the Senate and in the White
House are gonna not are just pissed at
these young people yeah by the way young
people they're not even that young so I
feel like that's what we're going to be
more and more old people are going to be
talking about how young people are unfit
because they're desperately like in any
normal pla any normal culture or normal
TV network Joey BR would be gone no she
wouldn't have yeah she's I she's just
there she's just basically inherited
that spot maybe they can't move her
yeah that could be that could be it
fossilizing yes it's actually
grown they have to take and they find
the remote control in a fold she's a
tree person she's a tree person catch is
it true shouldn't it when somebody says
something like these people are dumb
shouldn't there be an app that then like
connects these people together and they
have to prove that they're smarter yeah
I just don't think she's very good I
given examples
if you're I mean if you want to prove
Republicans are dumb and the one example
you pick is the literal biotech
executive like
Republicans are so stupid like that one
guy who's a biotechnology entrepreneur
who graduated from Harvard Law School
and is a stock analyst and worth
hundreds of millions of dollars idiot
I think anyone else yeah but at least
she still has her looks oh
no
no are we stupid for turning to Joy for
political analysis
no well I think you know you can turn to
her for compliments I mean Marjorie
Taylor green she called her a young
Republican that's that's fantastic that
is a compliment she should be retweeting
that yes for sure what else what else he
got Lou come on keep it going well well
when you said that you stuck to that
chair I hope they're moving her to stop
bed sores they flipper they flipper then
they but they put the talcum powder on
and yeah Wheeler around to the park she
stares at the squirrels she tries to eat
them
well she scares them away is what she
does yes exactly by the way do I make
fun of the view but it's because they
are relentlessly always calling people
racist and I and there's nothing worse
than than pegging somebody as a racist
so you can make fun of their looks
because that's like you can change your
looks right but you could ruin
somebody's career if you call him a
racist that's my justification
all right
well that went over well
all right up next why did the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame disown the founder of
Rolling Stone hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else